[Musique]
tous ces jouets la nuit dernière dans la
nuit du 16 au 17 mai aux alentours de C2
heures du matin à la loterie de la draft
NBA le prestigieux championnat de basket
nord-américain a livré son verdict les
Spurs de San Antonio décroche le premier
choix pour sélectionner un jeûne sport
du basket en vue de la saison prochaine
la franchise texane devrait donc
recruter le 22 juin prochain jour de la
draft 2023 livlinois Victor Wayne bagnat
premier une place de numéro 1 on
rappelle que le joueur français a foulé
ses premiers parquets dans les Yvelines
au club de l'Entente Le Chesnay
Versailles on débriefe tout de suite
cette actualité avec Mike Mokongo
bonjour Mike bonjour basketteur
international de la République
centrafricaine tout récents joueurs de
l'ascra vous êtes d'ailleurs à habitant
des Yvelines et vous comptez une longue
carrière derrière vous dans le basket un
club pour citer un par lequel vous êtes
passé celui de Monaco qui a une
actualité européenne en ce moment et
vous êtes aussi quelque part le
consultant de basket de 70 puisque vous
intervenez très régulièrement dans
l'émission si on parle espagnol pour le
grand public de voir Victor web benyama
rejoindre très probablement les Spurs ça
évoque tout de suite le nom de Tony
Parker la légende du basket français qui
a gagné avec l'équipe texane quatre
titres de NBA il y a évolué pendant près
de 20 ans borisio aussi a joué du côté
des Spurs entre 2011 et 2016 c'était la
meilleure destination la destination
idyllique pour Victor web benyama de
rejoindre l'espace tout d'abord wow un
perfo une performance historique pour
Victor et toute sa famille et notamment
aussi le basket français et on est
vraiment ravis de le voir là parce que
voilà quand on parle tout de suite de
son entonnoir si on pense à un coach
légendaire qui est Greg Popovic un
entraîneur vraiment qui a révolutionné
le basketball avec des garçons comme
voilà team Duncan Ginobili notamment
Tony Parker aussi 2127 matchs de NBA un
coacher par par Greg Popovic exactement
pour moi aujourd'hui c'est voilà c'est
un des meilleurs coachs au monde avec
Phil Jackson et puis voilà son entonnoir
c'est c'est une culture une identité de
basket un savoir-faire un environnement
qui est sain c'est vraiment tout ce
qu'on pouvait lui souhaiter et puis
aussi il a une double culture il connaît
bien les joueurs français en général
donc voilà franchement super super
content pour eux même si c'est une
franchise récemment qui qui réalise des
saisons qui sont vraiment en donci en la
vie encore cette année une saison qui
est extrêmement difficile pour eux je le
rappelle s'ils étaient dans cette
loterie de la droite et s'ils sont
arrivés numéro 1 c'est parce qu'ils ont
terminé dans le bas du classement NBA
ils sont pas qualifiés en playoff bien
sûr tout à fait il faisait partie des
trois équipes qui avaient 14% de chances
même si on sait que des fois il peut
avoir des scénarios incroyables parce
qu'elle a la loterie c'est vraiment un
ping-pong c'est mais voilà on est super
ravi pour pour son Antonio et un projet
qui va être construit autour de Victor
justement il y a des garçons qui aussi
intéressant dans cette équipe là Kindle
Johnson dénive à sel Jeremy Sochaux
voilà ils ont des jeunes qui sont
intéressants après il va falloir voir
est-ce que popovitch va continuer ou pas
il y a aussi des suspicions un petit peu
autour de ça mais voilà moi je pense
qu'il va il va continuer à coacher
jusqu'à 90 ans étant donné que Victor il
sera là donc ça sera sympa ouais plus de
70 ans pour Greg Popovic qui a quand
même aussi un qui est connu pour avoir
une capacité à faire progresser les
joueurs en NBA d'ailleurs on peut citer
aussi deux noms qui sont passés du côté
des Spurs puisque les Spurs avaient déjà
eu le choix numéro 1 de la draft en 87
et en 97 il y avait eu David Robinson et
timoncan deux grands champions tous les
deux titrés en NBA qui ont été tous les
deux MVP qui figurent aujourd'hui au
Hall of Fame ça ne dure que des bonnes
choses pour Victor et Mania mala vous le
dites en plus à priori au vu des
récentes prestations de des Spurs il va
être placé au centre du projet non
forcément c'est lui le franchise player
comme ils le disait aux États-Unis et le
projet va être pensé autour de lui vont
construire autour de lui et voilà à
propos vite il est connu justement pour
son sa capacité à développer les joueurs
les rendre meilleur on a vu un garçon
comme quoi elle a l'air qui a joué un
NBA qui a commencé par les sports où
personne ne pensait à ce niveau là et
donc voilà moi je pense que c'est ce
qu'il faut c'est ce qu'il fallait pour
lui et puis il a un grand frère Tony
Parker qui connaît bien la région qui
connaît le coin donc il sera aussi lui
donner des bons conseils et je tiens
aussi à féliciter justement l'agence
comme sport parce que ils ont fait un
très bon boulot je trouve qu'ils ont une
intelligence à penser ce projet sujet là
un petit peu comme à l'image de cette
année avec les métropolitains 92 autour
de lui un environnement sain pour que
lui justement il puisse bien travailler
les mettre 92 dans le club dans lequel
il a évolué cette saison dans lequel il
évolue toujours il y a des playoffs qui
s'ouvrent aussi pour ce club des Metz 92
19 ans le monde a ses pieds on a parlé
souvent de ces dimensions incroyables
c'est 2 mètres 21 pour Victor web
benyama et ce qu'il a les clés pour
réussir est-ce que c'est pas une
montagne trop grande pour lui c'était
NBA tout d'abord on parle là d'un joueur
quand même
hyper hyper hyper suivi déjà alors qu'il
est même pas encore un NBA et en parla
d'un d'un garçon qui a un potentiel
incroyable entre l'allerge de la
technique et la taille et on sait que
voilà c'est un garçon qui a des
attributs de de joueurs extérieurs il
est vite il est délié dribble bien il
est capable de tirer il a vraiment tout
pour lui au fait ça ça fait de lui un
basketteur vraiment hybride et on le
compare beaucoup à des garçons comme
Kevin Durant Dirk nowitzky voilà moi je
pense que il faut que toutes les
planètes soient alignées pour lui
d'ailleurs là il c'est une bonne
franchise quel est son entonnoir
maintenant il faut construire autour de
lui il faut lui donner l'opportunité de
continuer à performer aussi à le facteur
blessure qui est aussi important on sait
que ça pue l'handicapé ces dernières
années un peu moins cette saison où il a
eu un peu plus de continuité exactement
c'était une des questions cette année
mais cette année il fait plus de 50
matchs et donc je pense qu'il a répondu
aussi à ça et d'où le projet qui était
justement qui puisse faire un match par
semaine et lui permettre justement de
préparer son corps qu'est-ce que il doit
travailler à votre avis sur quels
aspects il doit travailler pour réussir
cette nouvelle étape dans sa carrière
alors tout d'abord ça va être
intéressant de voir comment ils vont le
faire jouer parce que Victor c'est un
poste 4 Puteaux un poste 4 qui tire de
l'extérieur qui peut aussi jouer au dos
au panier qui peut aller face au panier
donc ça serait important pour lui de
prendre un petit peu de masse parce que
de temps en temps je pense que dans le
dans la NBA moderne il va des fois
passer poste 5 ensuite il y a aussi son
tir extérieur à 3 points qui doit
perfectionner parce que cette année tu
iras 30% la ligne NBA elle est beaucoup
plus longue cette mètres 23 c'est un
garçon qui doit aussi progresser dans
dans sa capacité à prendre les bonnes
décisions donc voilà et puis après
c'est difficile à dire quand tu fais une
saison aussi incroyable comme il fait
mais je pense que voilà il a tout pour
lui pour réaliser une belle saison on
lui fait en tout cas de pleine réussite
dans cette nouvelle étape de la NBA la
draft c'est le 22 juin prochain
normalement sauf grande surprise donc
Victor HUG benjama qui devrait rejoindre
les Spurs de San Antonio ça saison n'est
pas terminée puisque je le disais il y a
les playoffs avec les mètres 92 qui
seront opposés à Cholet pour les
playoffs de cette
pro A2 basket merci beaucoup Mike
d'avoir parlé de cette actualité avec
moi merci merci beaucoup à vous aussi et
j'ai bien envie de finir sur une
dernière chose allez-y je voudrais
encore féliciter mon ami à laver qui
fait partie des hommes importants au
club de métropolitain ce qui en fait un
bon boulot autour de Victor féliciter
aussi et son argent et aussi et aussi
voilà tout le basket français doit se
réjouir devant un garçon à ce niveau là
on doit lui donner toutes les capacités
et les moyens de pouvoir y arriver et
franchement on est vraiment fiers
j'espère que la région c'est super fière
de ça on va revenir plus longuement sur
cette actualité dans la prochaine
émission si on parlait sport sur TV 78
[Musique]